by travelpod member myjob cohen i'm
professor of populations at the
Rockefeller University and at Columbia
University in New York City why should
you consider taking a course in
demography in college you will be
growing up in the generation where the
baby boomers are going into retirement
and dying you will face problems in the
aging of the population that have never
been faced before you will hear more and
more about migration into the United
States and in some cases out into Europe
and out between rural areas and cities
you need to understand as a citizen and
as a taxpayer and as a voter what's
really behind the arguments I want to
tell you about the past present and
future of the human population so let's
start with a few problems right now
a billion people are chronically hungry
that means they wake up hungry they're
hungry all day and they go to sleep
hungry a billion people are living in
slums not the same billion people but
there's some overlap living in slums
means they don't have tenure in their
homes they don't have infrastructure to
take the garbage away they don't have
secure water supplies to drink nearly a
billion people are illiterate try to
imagine your life being illiterate you
can't read the labels on the bottles in
the supermarket if you could get to a
supermarket 2/3 of those people who are
illiterate are women and about 200 to
215 million women don't have access to
the contraceptives they want so that
they can control their own fertility
this is not only a problem in developing
countries about half of all pregnancies
are unintended those are examples of
population problems
[Music]
demography gives you the tools to
address and to understand these problems
it's the study of populations of humans
and non-human species that includes
viruses like influenza the bacteria in
your gut plants that you eat animals
that you enjoy or that provide your
domestic animals and it includes
nonliving objects like lightbulbs and
taxicabs and buildings because these are
also populations and it includes the
study of these populations in the past
present and future using quantitative
data and mathematical models as tools of
analysis
I see demography as a central subject
related to economics to human wellbeing
as in material terms related to the
environment to the well-being of the
other species with which we share the
planet and culture which affects our
values and how we interact with them the
key fact you need to remember is that
since the inventions of Agriculture
between 6,000 and 14,000 years ago the
population of the earth the human
population has grown 1,000 fold from
approximately seven million maybe
fourteen thousand years ago to nearly
seven billion this year put three zeros
on the end of seven million you get
seven billion over the same interval the
earth has not gotten any bigger the
continents haven't expanded a
thousandfold or at all the oceans are
the same size as they were before the
atmosphere is the same size as it was
before so the question that concerns a
lot of people and me is whether the
impact that seven billion people or more
in the future will have on the earth
will endanger our own well-being and the
well-being of other species on the earth
we know that humans have already caused
the extinction of many species question
is is that going to come back and bite
us and if so in what ways demography
provides us with a reliable way to
imagine and to reimagine the future so
let's get down to some nitty-gritty
details here about 2,000 years ago there
were roughly a quarter of a billion
people on the planet today there are
almost 7 billion more than 6/7 of that
growth in fact more than six seventh of
the growth since the beginning of humans
50,000 years ago has occurred in the
last 200 years to go from a quarter of a
billion to half a billion took 16
centuries so we reached about half a
billion humans about 1600 more or less
the human population of the earth if it
were growing exponentially would go from
a quarter of a billion to half in 16th
centuries and from half to one in
another sixteenth centuries what
actually happened was that the human
population of the earth reached a
billion around 1800 because of
foodstuffs that came from the new world
to the old notably potato and corn or
maize and because many of the people who
were overcrowded in Europe went to
America where there were fertile and
unoccupied lands to use so the east-west
exchange the Columbian Exchange across
the Atlantic liberated population growth
in the European sector there was a
similar development in Japan an
acceleration of population growth around
the same time in 1800 the Industrial
Revolution began and the population
doubled from 1 billion to 2 billion by
1930 1927 we don't know exactly why
don't we know exactly because we didn't
have censuses that covered the whole
world at that time so it's a
retrospective guess so our doubling
times went from 1600 years to
years 1600 to 1800 to 130 years 1800 to
1930 the next doubling from 2 billion to
4 billion took only 44 years 1974 so
until the last half century human
population growth has been faster than
exponential but this slide that you've
been looking at is like a shower curtain
what it reveals is a little less
interesting than what it conceals and so
I'd like to zoom in on the part of
history from 1950 to now we've zoomed in
to the last 50 years the red vertical
line on the slide is now and it begins
on the left side in 1950 and runs up to
2011 and what you see is that the annual
population growth rate reached a peak of
about 2.1 percent per year in the years
1965 to 1970 and since then has fallen
by half to about 1.1 percent per year so
for the last two thousand years at least
except for the black death in the 14th
century the population growth rate was
going up up up up up and around 1965 it
began to decline if you look there's a
sharp dip before 1965 a very sharp
valley that is the Great Leap Forward in
China which killed about 30 million
people unnecessarily but the global peak
of 2.1 percent per year has since led to
a decline by 1/2 so in absolute terms
and in percentage terms the number of
people were adding to the planet has
begun to slow
since 1950 humans have made the swiftest
voluntary change in reproduction in
human history around 1950 the average
number of children per woman per
lifetime was very close to five today
the average number of children per woman
is about 2.5 or 2.6 in other words
billions of people have changed their
reproductive behavior to lower the
number of children born in a lifetime
from five to two and a half but not
everywhere in sub-saharan Africa the
decline has been much less from perhaps
six point six children to five point one
over the second half of the 20th century
to understand the consequences of this
fall to two and a half children per
woman you need to know what is meant by
replacement level fertility so I am
going to introduce that by telling you
about the theory of bathtubs a regular
bathtub with no stopper water comes in
and water goes out now water coming in
corresponds to births to the earth and
water going out corresponds to death and
the level of the bathtub corresponds to
the total population size so if the
number of births just matches the number
of deaths the population stays steady
and that's the replacement level
fertility now you're asking yourself
what is the replacement level of
fertility the answer is about 2.1
children per woman
there has been an amazing transformation
in the distribution of fertility across
the world in the last half century
I want you to look carefully at this
slide the vertical line is replacement
level fertility the horizontal axis is
total fertility rate children per woman
per lifetime and the vertical axis is
the percent of world population so it's
zero at the bottom a quarter half 75
percent and a hundred percent at the top
in 1950 the black line that's at the
bottom practically everywhere women were
having more than replacement level
fertility there on the right of the red
line by 1975 roughly a quarter of women
had moved to the left of replacement and
three-quarters were still over to the
right in 2003 this was not in any
newspaper anywhere but it was a very
important event in 2003 half of all the
women in the world were having
replacement level or less they moved to
the left of the red line and now more
than half of humanity lives in a country
at or below replacement level fertility
it's the first time in human history
that this has happened and it's
important but you remember that the
total fertility rate the average number
of children per woman is at 2.5 not 2.1
and that's because on this curve the
green curve the folks with high
fertility are further to the right of
the red line than most of the folks with
low fertility are to the left so the
average is skewed to the right so we
still have a growing population but this
change is continuing and how fast it
continues is something that you as
voters as potential scientists as
citizens will influence by what you
choose to do about the 215 million women
who have an unmet
for contraception so much for the past
let's go on to the present this is a
population pyramid it's one of the basic
descriptive tools of demography and you
should understand what it is let's start
with the left side of the picture the
horizontal axis the width of the bar
tells you how many people there are and
the vertical axis corresponds to age
group so the lowest bar is for people
aged 0 to 4 with males on the left and
females on the right the next bar is
people aged 5 to 9 the top bar is 85 or
90 and what you see is that in the rich
countries there are about as many people
aged let's say 0 to 4 as there are age
85 or 90 but it's basically a slender
column now compare it with the age
pyramid for the poor countries the base
of the pyramid is enormous compared to
the number of elderly so there are many
more workers to support the elderly per
elderly person the width of the bar
again is number of people so in the
ranges from 5 to 14 or 5 to 19 that's
the school age population it means that
the challenge of educating those
children is much greater in the
developing countries than it is in the
rich countries because those bars keep
getting wider as the developing
countries pump in more children at the
bottom of the pyramid the age groups
move up with time as they get older and
so the larger school age population is
followed ten years later by a much
larger military age population so if you
look at the age groups 15 to 30 you can
see that the potential military force in
the developing countries vastly exceeds
that in the rich countries it doesn't
mean it's military power for them it
means they can afford a military
engagement in a way that the human
resources of the rich countries make
very difficult increasingly difficult so
where's the growth going the demographic
growth is happening in the countries
that can least afford to deal with the
additional
population what's the average income the
reason we call or which country is rich
is that their average income is about
$32,000 a year per person and in the
poor countries it's about five thousand
dollars a year what fraction of people
are living on less than $2 a day nobody
lives on less than $2 a day in the rich
countries and 51% just about half in the
poor countries in other words about
three and a half billion people on our
planet are living on $2 a day or less
you might ask yourself if things are so
bad there how is it that their
population is growing so rapidly and the
fact is that the difference in death
rates is much smaller than the
difference in fertility rates so even
though a higher fraction of children die
before they reproduce the average number
of children that people have when they
do reproduce in the poor countries more
than compensates for the increase in the
death rate so that's why we have rapid
population growth at the same time that
we have high mortality because we have
even higher fertility it's an important
general question how does the rich world
benefit from the prosperity and
development of the poor world there are
lots of different answers you can give
one is purely economic richer people in
China and Africa will buy more American
music CDs and more movies and more
software and more high-tech engines from
General Electric and more products
because they have more means to buy so
that's one kind of an answer a second is
public health there are millions of
flights in both directions from the poor
countries to the rich countries every
year and the microbes don't know about
passports and they cross from Mumbai to
New York just
fast as they go from New York to Mumbai
and when there are outbreaks of
drug-resistant tuberculosis those can
travel around the world and they pose a
danger to me and to you guys so we have
an interest in the health and well-being
a direct personal interest in the health
and well-being of people in poor
countries so now we've talked about the
demographic past and the demographic
present and next we're going to talk
about the demographic future Woody Allen
said eternity is very long especially
near the end so we're not going to talk
about eternity we are only going to talk
about the near-term future how much of
the future is relevant to you well
according to the United States life
tables published by the National Center
for Health Statistics an 18 year old in
the United States in the year 2011 has a
91 percent chance of surviving to 2050
91 percent based on survival rates in
2006 if you behave wisely and if
economic and medical progress continue
you have at least that good a chance of
making it to 2050 so we're going to talk
about the world from now to 2050 I can
say with confidence that four things
will happen over the next 40 years or so
the world's population will get bigger
it will grow more slowly it will be
older in the sense that the fraction of
older people will increase dramatically
and it will be more urban and I'm going
to go through each of those for to
explain some of the details what we
don't know too much about is what will
be the future of migration the future of
household structures and the future of
families we have some ideas about that
but that's relatively less certain
this graph shows curves of the history
and future population out to 2050 at the
top the curve shows the anticipated
population if fertility remains at the
level it is today and there's no further
decline in fertility that's called the
constant fertility assumption and it
shows that the world would go to about
11 billion people by 2050
however if fertility drops as it has
dropped in the past the medium
projection of the UN Population division
is that population would rise to about 9
point 1 billion by 2050 so that's a
difference of two billion in other words
we're counting on a continuing decline
in fertility to lower the population
size by about two billion by 2050 what
we do between now and 2050
will have a huge impact on how difficult
it is to feed house shelter educate and
provide health for the billions of
people on the planet in 2050 it will
affect enormous range of human problems
it's possible the population growth
would end before 2100 depending on the
choices we make now what choices am i
talking about choices like educating
women providing credit to women in
countries where women are not allowed to
have credit providing reproductive
health care so that women are not forced
as they are in some countries to have
children when they don't want to raising
the age of marriage so that 12 year olds
13 year olds and 14 year olds are put
into marriage there's a lot of things we
can do to raise people including even
women raise people's control over their
own lives
and we should be doing those things a
second fact about the future is that the
population is going to grow more slowly
the slowing will depend on what we do
now by 2050 in the medium projection
from the United Nations Population
division the world will be growing by 31
million people a year what's it doing
now it's growing by 76 million people a
year in the poor countries population
will be growing by 32 million a year
while in the rich countries population
will actually be declining by a million
people a year already today in 2011
population is declining in more than 50
countries not well known what's
happening here is a shift in
childbearing desires and action from
quantity to quality as people urbanize
as people get educated as wealth
improves people are making greater
investments in a smaller number of
children so we've talked about
population size growth rate the next is
AG so by 2050 there will be about three
times as many elderly as children this
is the first time in human history that
the elderly population has outnumbered
the young population so what who cares
well aging effects energy demand so even
if you're interested in the environment
you need to know about the age structure
of populations older householders at
least in the United States India and
China the three countries where it's
been studied in detail spend more than
younger households measured by the age
of the head on utility services and
health care utilities are the most
energy intensive part of the household
budget that's not the only reason to
care the rise in the fraction of elderly
poses an increasing challenge to a
relatively reduced number of work
years and it's possible that the
well-being of elderly people could
improve if they're educated or could get
worse if they are warehoused in old
people's homes we know for example that
people who are educated in their youth
have much lower disability when they get
older and in fact disability rates at
any given age in the United States have
been dropping by about one and a half
percent per year for the last 25 years
so there are far fewer disabled elderly
now than there used to be that's the
meaning of 60 is the new 40 50 is the
new 30 people are healthier at older
ages that's a result of investment in
education in youth so there are policy
implications for a rising aged
population we better invest in educating
people when young and the last of the
four topics is cities and I'm going to
give you a very simplified and boiled
down demographic history of the first
half of the 21st century in 2000 you
could divide the world into two equal
parts half rural and half urban so that
was about 3 billion rural and 3 billion
urban in 2050 the rural population will
still be at 3 billion and the urban
population will have doubled from 3
billion to 6 billion all of those
additional 3 billion urban people will
be in poor countries the equivalent of a
city of 1 million people will have to be
built every 5 days from now to 2050 and
all of them in poor countries so what's
the consequence
what is this massive shift towards
urbanization mean if we under invest in
cities we can go from a billion people
living in slums today to 4 billion
people living in
and if we invest in the cities if the
real-estate companies realize the
opportunities the incredible demand that
people have to live in decent housing we
could reduce the size of the slums so I
cannot give you a deterministic picture
I can tell you what's what would be
awful
we could have infectious diseases
rampant
we could have warfare in the cities we
could have disorder but that's not
necessary we could have clean water
supplies we could have security for
people in their houses that doesn't get
as much news attention but the point I
want to make is we have choices about
the future of cities and many things
about urbanization are positive and I
want to tell you a few of the things
that are positive not because they're
automatic but because they are positive
in fact and because we can enhance the
positive compared to rural areas urban
areas have lower fertility rates why I'm
a woman on the farm you might not think
so but I am okay I'm a woman on the farm
the more children I have the more help I
can have in collecting the water
collecting the firewood and attending to
the goats and sheep as soon as I move
into a city those children convert from
an asset to a liability I have to buy
them clothing I have to send them to
school there are school fees the
apartment is too small
incentives completely shift direction
urbanization makes people want to have
fewer children cities also have higher
usage of modern contraception and lower
unmet needs for contraception why I am a
woman you might not know it I don't have
to walk 15 miles to the nearest health
center and be exposed to the inspection
of my husband's friends when I go in for
contraception no when I'm in the city I
just go around the corner
and it's anonymous so urbanization
brings many features of liberation as
well as changing the incentives cities
concentrate economic productivity 80% of
the world's gross domestic product is
produced in cities although there are
only 50 percent of the world's people in
cities cities generate cultural assets
educational resources public health
resources medical care and they can
promote energy efficiency let me give an
example this graph shows the passenger
transport carbon dioxide per person the
denser the city the lower the amount of
carbon dioxide per person New York City
is reported according to the mayor's
office to have less than one-third the
carbon dioxide emissions per person of
the US average people take the subway
people ride the bus cities also have
hazards many cities are built along
coastlines coastlines are where the
continental plates of the oceans collide
with the continents that means there are
prone to earthquakes we just had the big
example in Japan but it's true all
around the world the Ring of Fire around
the Pacific Ocean coincides with where
the cities are because cities are
coastal a lot of the world's urban
people live near the coastline and
that's where the subduction zones are in
California I'm going to show you three
slides of New York City where I live
this is New York City as it is now the
red zone will be under water if the
water level rises by one meter on the
average one meter is probably more than
we'll have in the next 50 years but
could easily happen by the end of the
century at current rates now a six meter
rise would happen if the Greenland and
Antarctic ice masses melted six meters
is about 20 feet that would be a
catastrophe in many respects including
for me it's a little place over here in
New Jersey which is my favorite nudists
and it would be completely underwater so
that would be a terrible thing to happen
so cities are vulnerable to rising sea
level the coastal storms cities
concentrate people so they're vulnerable
to infectious diseases water supply
attacks and cities are excellent targets
for military and terrorist attacks as we
know in New York City and many other
cities used to be battles were fought on
battlegrounds no more they're fought in
cities and that will increasingly be the
case as cities concentrate assets urban
growth could affect the food supply
right now cities occupy 3% of the land
surface of the earth the arable land the
land where we can grow food well is
about 10 or 11 percent of the land
surface of the earth it's not surprising
that many cities are smack in the middle
of the best arable land because that was
where a food surplus could be easily
produced without having to ship the food
now if cities are going to double we
have another choice do we double the
area from 3% to 6% and eat up our arable
land literally or do we double the
density and keep the areas of the cities
constant at 3% this is a choice for the
future and it depends on zoning and
culture and real estate developers and
economics and choices that we make as
citizens how do we address the problems
we have there are three kinds of
solutions that people have put forward
bigger pie fewer Forks better manners
the bigger pie people say we should use
technology to increase production
the fewer Forks people say we should use
contraception to reduce population
growth
and we should consume less material
products and the better manners people
say we should eliminate violence
inequities between men and women
inequities between rich and poor
inequities between young and old we
should eliminate irrational subsidies
and just make things work more
efficiently get rid of corruption I took
a few years to try to figure out what's
my best way to support those three
strategies all of them and I came to the
conclusion that the best response would
be to educate all children boys and
girls well for 10 to 12 years
high-quality primary and secondary
education I realized there is no chance
of educating people if their brains
haven't been fed adequately in utero and
after birth especially for the first
three years so I am now moving around to
working on the problem of getting food
adequate good food to pregnant women
lactating women and infants up to the
age of three because there are many
countries where the time a child gets to
school it's too late the brain has lost
its capacity to learn so now we're
talking about food I started this
conversation saying that there are a
billion hungry people chronically hungry
I want to come back to this we depend on
other species here is a list of what
other species provide to humans and I'm
going to read the list because it's
important food for people feed for our
domestic animals fuel biofuel for
example and wood to burn biomass and in
many countries people burn dung the
waste products of animals that's an
important source of fuel fiber so we
depend on trees for men
a paper and other products fascination
we love to go to the zoo and see animals
we love to see wildlife when people go
out in nature they're thrilled if they
see a deer or some other kind of
wildlife in fact in Central Park the
German tourists are thrilled to see
squirrels we find animals fascinating
pharmaceuticals most of our drugs are
natural products tuned up to serve human
needs animals provide transport they
carry people places they provide
traction they pull plows they pull carts
other species provide symbiosis I've
talked about the animals not the animals
the bacteria that live in our guts and
they provide infection that can cause
disease so the question I want to
address now is can we grow enough food
to bring us to 2050 without catastrophe
these are data from the Food and
Agricultural Organization in Rome they
are estimates of the number of people in
the world who are chronically
undernourished day after day the current
estimate is about nine hundred and
twenty five million people that's nearly
a billion and it is higher than the
number has been in the last 40 years
98% of these people live in poor
countries not only poor countries here
is something that shocked me and I hope
it was shocked you at some point during
2009 17 point 4 million US households
one household in seven in the United
States lacked enough money and other
resources to provide enough food for all
members of the household the current
level of food insecurity in the United
States is higher than it has been since
the USDA started collecting these
statistics by sample surveys in 1995 we
are at an all-time high of hunger in
this country so the question you should
be asking yourself is well
aren't we growing enough food what's the
problem the answer is less than half of
the grain that we grow goes into
people's mouths divide the world's grain
into six equal pieces one piece we use
to make biofuels starches for seed and
other industrial uses plastics 2 6 we
feed to our domestic animals of the rich
people those who have the means to
afford those animals and meat products
less than half the other 3 6 goes
directly into human mouths we could be
feeding 11 billion but we only feed half
of that amount five and a half billion
into human mouths we put machines and
animals in line before people who don't
have money to express demand in markets
hunger doesn't fit into our economic
theories it's economically invisible
because people who are very poor can't
enter the market and plunk down their
cash and say I want that they are
invisible economically so my hunger does
not affect your costs for grain this is
a problem with our economics and it's a
reflection of our values do we value the
hunger of other people
so here's Joel's formula for how to
solve the world's problems
well population let's go at it with all
hammer and tongs eliminate unintended
pregnancies and educate all children to
give people control over their bodies
and their own lives
economics open credits and markets to
small farmers a majority of the world's
farmers are women they are the ones out
in the field actually doing the work
eliminate perverse subsidies subsidies
in rich countries make it very difficult
for poor farmers to enter markets
because they lower the price in
artificial ways and let's raise the
incomes of the poor environment use the
best farmlands for farms
and internalize the external cost of
Agriculture get rid of the pollution and
use chemicals in a way that doesn't
damage the environment forth culture
promote healthy diets and value adequate
nutrition for every person I would add
one other thing under this culture
question and that is we need to fund
more research in agricultural
productivity for the crops that matter
in poor countries not only for the
industrial crops that fund our biofuel
have it but for the crops that provide
food to the poor when you walk away from
this conversation I hope that you'll
remember that population interacts with
economics the environment and culture so
that you immunize yourself against
people who will try to sell you an
overly simple bill of goods and there
are a lot of people there are people who
say demography is destiny all we have to
do is get a contraceptive in every pot
and we'll solve the world's problems
that's wrong and there are people who
say all we have to do is get the market
right let the market take care of all
the prices in my view that is equally
wrong and much more dangerous there are
people who say it's only a matter of law
and getting the laws right yeah but it's
also a matter of technology and
contraception and economics and they're
people who say forget about the people
let's just save the environment I don't
believe that because I'm a human being
and I value other human beings we've got
to get all of these things working
together and the environment can be on
the side of human well-being because
poor rural people depend directly on the
environment for their sustenance if they
want to have a sustainable sustenance
they have to have a sustainable
environment demography makes it possible
to imagine and to reimagine the future
I'd encourage any freshman sophomore
junior senior adult high school
student I'm not age prejudiced anybody
to consider demography it's not the only
field that offers these attractions but
it does offer them in spades it's really
very attractive
first of all demography gives you tools
and analytical perspectives to
understand better the world around you
secondly it gives you equipment to solve
problems
mentally and third it is the means to
intervene more wisely and more
effectively in the real world to improve
the well-being not only of yourself
important as that may be but of people
around you and of other species with
whom we share the planet so it's it
prepares you to go out and do something
that's worth doing for a larger good
than only yourself so there's an old
saying if I am NOT for myself who will
be but if I am only for myself
what am i and if not now when
so now is the time pull up your pants
and get to work thank you
[Music]